I don't need to say that being wrong is
the same thing as being creative what we
do know is if you're not prepared to be
wrong you'll never come up with anything
original if you're not prepared to be
wrong and creativity experts Sir Ken
Robinson in 2006 delivered one of the
most popular TED talks of the whole and
time in it he explains why education
systems should nurture creativity not
undermine it Ted is a nonprofit
organization known for spreading ideas
around the globe it's a place where
people can give short powerful talks on
almost any topic from procrastination to
doodling to psychology and the brain TED
Talks rack up more than 3.4 billion
views every year they've been translated
into more than 110 languages we're
really excited this morning to announce
a new partnership with Ted our new
series called ideas that matter will
feature Ted speakers right here on CBS
this morning
the discussions will highlight
individuals and ideas that help shape
our world Chris Anderson is the curator
and head of Ted good morning good
morning good to see you excited about
this partner so why are you excited
about this partnership I'm excited
because ideas a heroes that don't often
get the recognition they deserve when
you it's crazy when you think about it
like that how tiny a thing an idea is
this is little spark in someone's head
but they have so much power because they
can change how that person sees the
world what they do and they can spread
from person to person and so they have
they have just untold impact over the
long term and it's it's kind of amazing
when you you look back in history and
see the kinds of things that you know
that the news stories or the events that
we usually talk about often ideas just
get underplayed in the hope of this so
what's so wonderful is it that in this
time of shredded idea attention and
where everything feels bite-sized and
small these ideas as you say can change
lives people immerse themselves in them
they have a kind of deep connection with
them that we don't necessarily associate
with the pace of modern life yeah if you
have a problem in the world to solve
that problem it's going to take an idea
at some point and a person willing to
push that idea and persuade other people
that it is worth paying attention to
so this partnership will launch in 2019
what kinds of speakers do we expect to
hear from and the types of topics so
ideas can do lots of things you know
like you we often think of them as these
light bulb moments these inventions a
scientific discovery those things of
course can have you know huge influence
over time but ideas can also be things
that just correct a current problem in
the world it's like they give people a
different way of seeing the world so for
example you know right you couldn't you
can see the world as full of problems
and disasters and someone says no
actually no that's not the right way to
think about actually there's been
incredible progress
don't be so downhearted humans are
capable of making progress no that's
what Steven Pinker famously yeah and
ideas don't necessarily have an
expiration date to right you can go back
and watch an old TED talk and see it
completely differently a few years down
the road which of the TED talks have
surprised you the most
well that clip you just showed of Ken
Robinson you know he gave that talk back
in 2006 about about creativity and that
has become more and more relevant now
because as you look you know we look
forward to this scary future right now
well we don't know what jobs will be
like in the future it looks like robots
AI artificial intelligence will take
over so many jobs and one of the human
superpowers is going to be creativity
and so there's more reason than ever to
nurture it so that that talk seems even
more relevant now than it did at the
time we all want more human superpowers
right I do want to give people a sense
of though who the type of speakers are
and one of them is Jan Raider she's a
fire chief from West Virginia who's been
helping fight the opioid epidemic I
looked in she's like the first female
fire chief in Huntington West Virginia
tell us a little bit about her yeah so
this is a classic case where the opioid
epidemic seems like such an overwhelming
problem you know it's just how did we
get into this state it's just it's so
shocking that so many people in so many
parts of America and us around the world
you know are addicted and can't run
their lives like they would most
people's response is to kind of throw up
their hands or just get really angry her
response was different it was like okay
what could we do about this
and in her town they she has led an
initiative to find a unique solution to
this that can actually work both with
with addicts and with frontline
responders to it to change their
thinking about how to tackle this
problem I like the idea of focusing on
that ideas that matter can also be
solution based ideas to big problems
that we face exactly in the crop from
2018 there are some that that you like
that are that are about being receptive
to new ideas right yes absolutely I mean
you know what one of the things that we
all worry about a lot right now is is
the increasing division between between
people you know that the sort of group
that the narrowing of the world into
these sort of partisan bubbles where we
just lob insults at each other on
Twitter or Facebook and and start to
hate each other and even feel disgusted
by each other this is really dangerous
for it and so I think some of the most
important ideas shared in the last year
have been what what do we do about that
and on the one hand there are things we
probably need to do just in terms of how
we structure social media there was a
talk given by Jaron Lanier who was
pointing out that by pushing forth and
free services that that was going to be
a problem and sorry we're out of time
thanks so much Chris for being with us
we'll be right back